hey this is pressure Locker a safe has a
code lock that unlocks if you input the
correct four digits in any order the
lock is a keypad with the digits going
from zero to nine for example suppose
the unlock code is one zero zero zero
the safe will open for any order you
input those digits you can input exactly
that code or you could put the one in
the second position or you could put the
one in the third or the fourth position
or for another example consider the
unlock code one two three four the safe
will open for any permutation of the
same numbers the question is how many
different unlock codes are there to
unlock codes are equivalent if they
contain the same digits and they are
different if they do not use the same
digits can you figure it out give this
problem a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for the solution in
an ordered code lock there are ten
possible choices for each of the four
spots on the code making for total of 10
to the power 4 or 10,000 possible codes
in this unordered code lock we have to
avoid double counting
since codes like 1 0 0 0 and 0 1 0 0 are
equivalent unlock codes as there are the
same digits in a different order so one
way that we can count the unordered code
locks is to count the number of unique
digits in the unlock code we'll start
out by counting the number of unique
digits being equal to 1 how many ways
are there to choose this one digit while
there 10 choose 1 or 10 different digits
that we have once we choose that one
digit there's only one possible unlock
code which is using that same number for
times
so the number of different codes can be
enumerated and we can count that there
are 10 different codes if we have one
unique digit but what if we have two
unique digits the first thing is we need
to count how many ways there are to
choose these two digits there will be 10
choose 2 which equals 45 different ways
but even after we select the two digits
we can have more than one pattern when
you have one of the digits being
repeated three times or one can have the
other digit being repeated three times
or we can have both digits being
repeated two times suppose the digits
are 0 and 1 we can have the 0 repeated 3
times we can have the 1 repeated 3 times
or we can have both digits being equal
to 2 times so there are 3 possible
patterns once we select the two unique
digits so we take the 45 and multiply by
3 to get that there are 135 different
codes if we have two unique digits in
the unlock code but we could also have
three unique digits in the unlock code
now there will be 10 choose 3 ways to
choose these 3 digits
we also to consider the possible
patterns there will actually be 3
because each of the digits could be
repeated in the pattern if we have the
digits 0 1 & 2 we'd have the digit 0
repeated we'd have the digit 1 repeated
or we have the digit 2 repeated so we
take 120 multiplied by 3 possible
patterns to get to 360 finally we can
have four unique digits there will be 10
choose 4 which equals 210 ways to choose
the digits once we choose them there's
only one possible pattern because we
have to use each digit exactly once so
there will be 210 possible different
codes if we have four unique digits so
we can now get the total number of
different codes by adding up these
different possibilities this gets to our
answer of 715
there are a couple of observations to
make here first of all this is
tremendously smaller than the 10,000
codes when we had ordered codes and
second this method don't get to the
correct answer but it involves many
different steps and if you for example
just forget one of the possible patterns
you're going to get the wrong answer
because you're not going to multiply
correctly and then you're not going to
add up the correct numbers and it'll get
to the wrong answer so while this method
does work it is prone to miscalculation
and there are many steps where you can
make an error so you might ask is there
another way that we could get to the
answer more directly with fewer
computations the answer is yes there's
an elegant combinatorial method where
you count the number of non-negative
integer solutions to an equation so
we'll set this up by writing X sub I to
be the number of times digit I appears
in the unlock code we are going to
convert this problem into an algebra
problem we need each X sub I to be a
non-negative number between 0 and 4
because we could use each digit between
0 & 4 times in an unlock code
furthermore an unlock code uses 4 digits
so we need the sum of all the X sub i's
to be equal to 4 this means we have the
equation X sub 0 to X sub 9 being equal
to 4 this will be true for any valid
unlock code and in order to get a valid
unlock code the number of unlock codes
translates to the problem of how many
non-negative integer solutions are there
to this equation so it seems like we
haven't really made progress on this
problem we've taken this unlock code
problem and converted it to an algebra
problem which seems like it's going to
be much more difficult to solve I mean
how do we take into account when one
digit goes up we need to make sure
another digit doesn't exceed 4 so
amazingly there's a
clever way to count the number of
non-negative integer solutions and it is
a general method that we can use for
many problems like this so the trick is
to view the problem in terms of Stars
and Bars we take our answer of equals 4
and we say we'll imagine we have 4 stars
we want to divide them into 10 different
groups because we have 10 variables
going X sub 0 to X sub 9 we can create
10 different groups by using 9 bars
variable X sub 0 will be the first group
on the left then X sub 1 will be the
next group between 2 bars and so on
until XO 9 will be the group to the
right of the final bar for example let's
say we have 4 stars that are arranged as
such I'm now going to place nine
different bars I can place them either
next to another bar or I could place
them in between the stars so once we
place nine bars we can actually see that
there will be 10 different groups and we
can identify the groups with the
variables of our algebra equation so in
this arrangement of stars and bars we
can convert it into an equation where
only the variables X sub 3 X sub 4 and X
sub 6 are nonzero X sub 3 is equal to 1
X sub 4 is equal to 2 and X sub 6 is
equal to 1 this is a valid solution to
this equation
furthermore we can convert this into an
unlock code this would use the digit 3
the digit 4 2 times and the digit 6 once
so we have a connection between unlock
codes this algebraic equation and the
Stars and Bars representation now this
illustration is an unlock code that uses
three unique digits but I showed you
that the unlock code can also have one
two or four unique digits as well so let
me show you there's a
different Stars and Bars representation
which will get us to counting a
different number of unique digits in
this representation we have X sub 0
being equal to 1 and X sub 9 being equal
to 3 and all of the other variables
being equal to 0 again we have a valid
solution to this equation and this gives
us an unlock code 0 followed by three
nines the digit 0 is used once and the
digit 9 is used three times so here we
have two unique digits in the unlock
code I'll show you another
representation of Stars and Bars where
we just have X sub 5 be equal to 4 this
will be the unlock code 5 5 5 5 where
the digit 5 is used four times and we
just have one unique digit in this
unlock code
well you'd also have the Stars and Bars
representation where we have four unique
digits here are the variables X sub 1 X
sub 2 X sub 7 and X sub 8 are equal to 1
we have another valid solution to this
equation and we have the unlock code 1 2
7 8 we have four unique digits so the
Stars and Bars representation will
actually capture all the non-negative
solutions to this equation and it will
count the number of unlock codes so now
we need to figure out how many ways can
we arrange four stars and nine bars well
notice that we have a total of 13
different items or 13 spots because we
have 4 stars and nine bars so once we
specify the placement of the nine bars
the four bar four stars will fill the
remaining positions so we start out with
13 different spots and once we have
these spots we place these bars in nine
of the different positions once we do
that we have exactly four different
spots left for the stars
so how many ways can we arrange 13 items
where we have nine bars well this will
be equal to thirteen choose nine which
is exactly 715 and notice we get two
exactly the same answer in a completely
different way without having to figure
out anything about the code patterns
multiplying them and adding them all up
so this is one calculation we have
thirteen choose nine that gets us to 715
now once you know this method it was
complicated to set up but now we can
actually use it to solve problems
generally so how can we solve the number
of non-negative integer solutions if we
have our variables summing up 2n well
notice we can represent this by having n
stars that we will divide into our
different groups using our -1 bars so we
have a total of n plus R minus 1 items
or n plus R minus 1 spots and each
ordering is specified once we select the
positions for the R minus 1 bars so the
number of solutions will be n plus R
minus 1 choose R minus 1 and it's one
calculation which will count the number
of non negative solutions it would also
count the number of unlock codes if we
had a different number for the unlock
code say being equal to five digits or
if we're using only a subset of the ten
different digits from 0 to 9 so you can
solve any of those problems using this
one formula did you figure it out and
which method did you use thanks for
watching this video please subscribe to
my channel I make videos on math and
game theory you can catch one of our
blog mind your decisions which you can
follow on Facebook Google+ and patreon
you can catch me on social media at
pressure Walker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description